Narrator: From a car left
sitting for six years
to a flooded leather bag
and a boat cover left
outside to face the elements,
these forgotten items became
breeding grounds for mold.
We spoke with experts to find out
how they cleaned and sanitized them.
Our first expert is Brent
Dicesare from WD Detailing.
He shows us how he and his team
clean a car filled with
rainwater and mold.
They start by pumping oxygen into the car
using an ozone machine.
The oxygen suffocates and kills bacteria.
They remove the seats and vacuum out
all of the water that
has pooled on the floor.
Because the sunroof of
the car won't close,
rainwater has dripped inside
and collected for six years.
Brent uses an air compressor
with a Tornador attachment
to blast the carpet fibers
with an all-purpose
cleaner mixed with water.
Then he sprays extractor
soap on the carpet
before using an extractor
to shoot it with hot water.
The extra moisture will
help to reduce friction
as he uses a drill brush
to agitate the soap.
Too much friction could
further damage the carpet.
After agitating, he uses the extractor
to suck the soap and
water out of the carpet.
The team sprays the doors
with a bacteria-killing
solution called Tri-Clean
before scrubbing them down
with a Tornador attachment.
To dry the doors, they
use a microfiber cloth
and another Tornador
attachment that blows out air.
They vacuum the seats to
collect any surface debris
and then spray them
with a leather cleaner.
Then they use a Colourlock brush
to scrub deep into the pores of the seats,
making sure they don't
use too much pressure.
The team sprays the seats
again and uses a steamer
to kill any lingering bacteria.
To clean the wheels,
they start by pressure washing them
to remove initial dirt and grime.
Then they spray them with heavy acid,
agitate them, and wash away the solution.
Mold has even accumulated
on the exterior of the car,
so they pressure wash it twice,
applying paint-safe
degreaser between sessions.
Finally, they spray soap onto
the car using a foam cannon,
wipe it down with microfiber mitts,
and rinse it with water.
To prevent a car stored
outside from becoming moldy,
it's best to store it
under a car cover or tarp.
Our next expert is Charlotte Staerck
from The Handbag Clinic.
She demonstrates how her team
restores a leather handbag
that looks unsalvageable
due to mold growth.
This handbag was sitting
in the back of its owner's
wardrobe when a pipe burst,
leaving the perfect
environment for mold to spread.
After assessing the handbag,
an artisan from Charlotte's team begins
scraping the mold away using
a variety of hand tools.
Metal tools can be used in areas
where the leather is harder-wearing
or the mold is not sticking to the bag.
Otherwise, a wooden tool is used
to avoid scratching the leather.
Next, they use a brush to remove
any dry mold left over after scraping.
The artisan sprays a mold-removal solution
onto the bag to ensure the mold is killed
so it won't grow back.
Finally, they apply an
in-house cleaner to the bag
to remove any harsh
chemicals or remaining dirt.
And then it's ready to
be returned to its owner.
This cover certainly did its job
protecting a boat from the elements,
but now it needs a good cleaning.
Mike Sadowski from Chet's Cleaning
gets it looking as good as new.
Mike sprays the moldy boat cover
with a chemical solution called DOT
and then allows it to dwell
for at least 30 minutes.
Then he uses a machine
called a Cimex to agitate.
The Cimex gently pulls apart
the fibers of the boat cover
so that dirt, mold, and
grime can be released.
He power washes with soap and water
to further break up the dirt,
and then he uses a broom
to push the pooled water
off of the boat cover.
This helps him see whether
he's missed any spots.
Mike puts the boat cover into a bath
to rinse off the chemicals
and then runs it through a rinse wringer
to squeeze out the water and
power wash it one more time
before hanging it to dry.
Mike recommends getting
boat covers cleaned
when they start to look dirty.
Applying water repellent
can also prolong the life
of a boat cover.